infrastructure fun yeah absolutely yeah
short but sweet cold open I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's February
22nd in the year 2023 the year is flying
freaking by we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals share
subscribe tap the notification Bell if
you have not as always we got a live
post game show at
reubenapport.locals.com right after the
show I've got a bit of a hectic day
today let's just do some housekeeping
real quick after the show today we are
going to be pre-taping tomorrow's show
which is a Community Q a you guys have
been submitting your questions already
and if you want to get some in last
second I think you can Daphne is paying
attention at this very moment look at
her staring at her computer very
intensely uh if you want to submit
questions reubenport.locals.com uh I'm
pre-taping the show because later today
I'm heading over to Sarasota because
Rumble is officially cutting the Blue
Ribbon at their new offices and Studios
as you guys know locals moved to Miami
about about eight months ago or so and
we've been shooting some stuff over
there Open Studios and offices over
there and now rumble's taking over the
West Coast so we have huge offices
Studios and then on Friday morning after
the Blue Ribbon ceremony and a whole
bunch of big names are going to be there
and all that good stuff I will be doing
the first ever live stream from the
rumble Studio I think that's going to be
at about 9 30 a.m so it's going to be a
different time than normal just because
of a couple logistical things going on
over there but we will only be live
streaming that on Rumble and on locals
not on YouTube so in case you have not
subscribed already to rumble.com
reubenreport or our locals Community go
ahead and do that that'll be the first
live stream there and I think there's a
whole bunch of interesting people that
will be there I can't say too much I
don't want to hint too much but maybe
some surprise guests and a bunch more so
anyway it's going to be a hectic couple
days but let's get to the program today
there are good things uh happening I
know people have been saying Dave you've
been very emotional on the show lately a
lot of f-bombs some more
genuflection than usual a lot of body
motions pounding on the desks calling
people mean names are there good things
happening and I think the answer to that
actually is yes one of the things I've
been telling you guys for a while is it
does seem like Republicans are starting
to show some teeth we're seeing that in
terms of Congress and now we're seeing
it in terms of a couple people
announcing that they are running for
president so obviously you've got Trump
already that's that's sort of the known
thing we know what it is we know who
Trump is there'll be surprises related
to Trump but there isn't a great
surprise around Trump right we know what
Trump is
have a sense that perhaps Rhonda said
this is going to run that is certainly
possible and even if he isn't running or
doesn't run or whatever it might be it
seems like all the attacks are going in
his Direction so he's doing something
right on that front uh then of course
Nikki Haley announced last week I happen
to like Nikki Haley a lot I think she
did a really really nice job as U.S
ambassador at the UN under Trump and you
know we were not in wars and all that
stuff and she did a fine job as
Republican governor of South Carolina so
she's doing her thing uh and then just
in the last 48 hours or so it was sort
of slightly leaking out for those of you
that are quote unquote very online
people uh Vivek Rama Swami who's been on
the show I consider him a friend we've
done a couple events together he's a
good dude he is a finance guy and a Tech
Pro and uh and and a really interesting
thinker and good communicator well he's
getting in too so the show today
is going to sort of be about the new
crop of people getting involved and the
media reaction to them because uh you're
not going to believe this guys but
generally if you're a republican with
good ideas and you can walk straight and
you can say a couple words in a row
without fumbling they will do everything
they can to destroy you so that is the
plan for today uh before we get to it
let me talk to you guys about Patriot
Supply uh you guys know with so much
chaos and danger in the world these days
I highly recommend you stock up on
emergency food right now let's face it
you're going to need this food and now
is the time to get it before it's too
late go to
mypatriotsupply.com and stock up with
their popular three-month emergency food
kit we've got a couple downstairs right
now when you do you'll get 200 worth of
survival gear as a free bonus you'll
need this gear When Things Fall Apart
apart or the grid goes down or anytime
you might have to fend for yourself
let's say you live in San Francisco and
the zombies start attacking your house
you got to do something right to see
everything you'll get go to
mypatriotsupply.com your 200 bonus comes
free with each three-month emergency
food kit you order that way everybody in
your family will be prepared but hurry
this offer won't last forever check this
off your list and sleep better knowing
your family won't suffer if the worst
case scenario ever happens go to
mypatriotsupply.com for free shipping
mypatriotsupply.com and now back to me
all right so let's jump right into it
Vivek Rama Swami has announced he is
running for president I think there is
going to be a broad wide swath of
Republicans representing a whole bunch
of different ideas but all part of what
I've been trying for I'd say a year or
two now to put together which is this
broad Coalition on the right of people
who have some differences some are a
little more libertarian some are a
little more socially conservative some
are the ex-libs whatever it might be
that we all actually love America and we
love freedom and we believe that this
experiment is good and worth continuing
and I think we're going to get a whole
bunch of Interest seeing people on those
debate stages and vivec jumped in
yesterday here is his announcement
we're in the middle of a national
identity crisis
Faith patriotism and hard work have
disappeared only to be replaced by new
secular religions like covetism
climatism and gender ideology
we hunger to be part of something bigger
than ourselves yet we cannot even answer
the question of what it means to be an
American
today the woke left preys on that vacuum
that has created a new Culture of Fear
in our country that has completely
replaced our culture of free speech in
America
and that is why today I am announcing my
run for president of the United States
this isn't just a political campaign
this is a cultural movement to create a
new American Dream for the Next
Generation if we can revive that dream
over fractious group identity then
nobody in the world not a nation not a
corporation not a virus is going to
defeat us that is what American
exceptionalism is all about
and that is what we will need to revive
to save this great nation
all right the messaging is good now put
aside whether you love Trump or you love
DeSantis or you love Nikki Haley or you
love anybody else uh this guy clearly is
a good communicator of the right ideas
uh he is a second generation American
his parents moved here from India he has
become a multi-multi-millionaire I think
he's worth a couple hundred million
dollars so there's a little bit of a
Ross Perot feeling to this I am not
sitting here telling you the guy is
going to be president I like him I'll
interview him I hopefully will interview
everyone that that runs for president
and and let them share their ideas but I
think his messaging is correct and on
point you know the other thing that he's
been doing over the last year is he runs
this fund called strive which is
basically a a reverse ESG fund that they
want the the companies that strive
invests in to have nothing to do with
ESG meaning nothing to do with the
social credit score and that you
actually would invest in companies who
want to make money and make good product
bucks not be part of the Wes ESG
campaign to act a certain way and have a
certain amount of diversity and oh my
God we have a lesbian on the board it's
very exciting so there is something good
here going on with vivec uh he actually
he posted that video for the official
launch and then he went on Tucker
Carlson and explained a bit more so it
does seem like
Don Lemon you know just a cable host but
this is a perfect illustration of where
identity politics wind up
when you stray from Universal principles
that bind us all under the same rules
exactly I mean we are in the middle of
this national identity crisis Tucker
where we have celebrated our diversity
and our differences for so long that we
forgot all of the ways we're really just
the same as Americans Bound by a common
set of ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago and that's what I'm
proud to say tonight that I'm running
for United States president to revive
those ideals in this country those basic
rules of the road meritocracy the idea
that you get ahead in this country not
on the color of your skin but in the
content of your character the idea that
you are allowed to speak freely yes to
be wrong sometimes as long as your
neighbor gets the same courtesy in
return the idea that the people who
elect to run the government by the way
are the people who actually run the
government basic rules of the road these
are the things that bind us together you
and I have different shades of melon you
know what I say so what that's not
beautiful that is not our strength our
diversity is meaningless if there's not
nothing greater that binds us together
across that diversity and the reason
that I'm running for president is to
revive those ideals and I believe deep
in my bones they still exist
yeah they do still exist and we've got
to return to them and that's what he's
talking about he's originally from Ohio
he went to Harvard as I said he founded
strive management I think he's an
excellent Communicator like he's clean
and clear and I think having him on that
debate stage is going to be really
really good he's pro-america he's Pro
what he's pushing there is the dream is
the dream that his parents came from
India for that my grand great
grandparents came from Eastern Europe
for that whoever you are watching this
that most likely your parents or
grandparents or great-grandparents
wherever they came from whether it was
South America or southeast Asia or
Western Europe or whatever all came here
for that thing that he's talking about
to fight for that meritocracy where your
skin color does not matter now what's
fantastic about this is we're going to
see the media have to once he gains a
little momentum and he will you're going
to see the media do all sorts of Tricks
because he's got brown skin and they
only like brown-skinned people when they
are sort of you know leftist NPC so he's
going to be a sellout and there's going
to be some weird anti-indian sentiment
which you're also seeing with Nikki
Haley by the way because Indians
generally don't fit the minority box
thing right they are largely successful
and they put a lot into education and
family see Jews see Chinese Americans
these are groups that do not fit in with
the identity politics hierarchy thus
must be destroyed a little more on
viveki put this tweet out and I wanted
to go through some of the bullet points
on this because I thought this was good
I challenge every GOP candidate to join
me in making some easy commitments end
affirmative action yes no more
race-based selection through government
wouldn't that be something okay I'm with
you vivec there you go number one
abandon climate religion yes we should
be allowed to question and ask and they
used to tell us the Earth was Cooling
and now it's getting hotter and they
don't want anyone living by the water
but Obama's got got a 30 million dollar
house in Martha's Vineyard etc etc that
would be good total decoupling from
China yeah do you think that maybe we
shouldn't have so much dependence when
it comes to medicine and equipment and
infrastructure and chips for our
computers and everything else from a
country that seemingly wants to take us
over that would be good eight year
limits for all federal federal
bureaucrats that's a direct direct drain
the swamp type approach we can't have
people that have been here for 40 years
sitting in their offices with their with
that bad lighting and the linoleum uh
just you know basically running the
government forever okay say no to
Central Bank digital currencies wouldn't
that be something that's a direct
assault on the wef we do not want
Central Bank digital currencies we don't
want to centralize what should be
inherently decentralized and we
certainly should care more about the
dollar than some some you know fake form
of currency that the wef is pushing out
uh release the state action file I'm
actually not totally sure what he means
by that one can we get a little bit
we'll get a little bit more info
on that one but it's not just Vivek
that's running I mentioned Nikki Haley
and you might remember from a few days
ago Don Lemon who subsequently had to
take a few days off from CNN after
making his ridiculously uh sexist and
ageist comments about Nikki Haley that
at 51 you know she's not in her prime
anymore well somehow Whoopi Goldberg who
is who she has literally become a human
whoopee cushion if you squeeze her
noxious gases comes out of her mouth I'm
sorry that was rather vile but she is
just absolutely awful here she is on The
View with fake conservative Alyssa Farah
Alyssa Farah Alyssa I think I've said
this to you uh well I've definitely
tweeted it at you but I just want to be
clear about this Alyssa if you're
watching
um you're getting let's say a million
bucks to be on The View for a year or
two there'll be probably a million you
probably have like a two-year deal it's
probably about a million million and a
half that's good cash most people would
like to make a million or a million a
half would you guys be interested in
that that would be something okay I
can't help you there but that would be
saying it most people would want you're
selling your soul to do it you are not
defending conservatism or any Republican
idea or anything and whoopee and joy and
the rest of them the second they are
done sucking your soul out of you which
you're giving to them on a plate anyway
they will never invite you to a wedding
or to a an event or to their house or
anything else anyway here is human
whoopee cushion Whoopi Goldberg and
complete conservative sellout Allison
Farah going after Nikki Haley for the
same exact thing that Don Lemon had to
take a couple days off for
it's time for a new generation of
leadership you're not a new generation
you're 51 what are you talking about
to DC though compared to DC that's a new
generation but it's not a new generation
she may be she may be younger than most
of those people but her rhetoric is the
same she's saying the same BS and I love
the young kid but you know what the only
way you're going to get younger people
to run dude is if you're out there
talking to people and saying run don't
sit here and say we need it to look like
us we know that we know that but we're
not going to vote for people who don't
have our best interests at heart let me
deal with the last part there we're not
going to vote for people who don't have
our best interests in heart what did
Ronald Reagan say the eight scariest
words in the English language I'm from
the government and I'm here to help
these people want the government to be
their daddy they want the government to
be their God I do not go away from me
government I don't like you very much I
don't need you yes if there is a natural
disaster it would be nice if somebody
could help out and I would like some
roads in a border beyond that I really
don't want anything to do with you
people but the fact that Whoopi is going
off on Nikki Haley's age now first off
Whoopi is 67. Nikki is 51. now I'm
actually not attacking Whoopi for her
age she has all of the wrong ideas
absolutely all of the wrong ideas it's
very sad watching what Bishop used to be
a great actress like everyone loved
Whoopi 20 years ago there was no one in
America that wasn't like oh whoop he's a
great actress she's funny as hell she
does the the comedy specials on HBO and
she's in Ghost and yeah what was the
well give me a Whoopi Goldberg movie uh
Sister Act thank you sister act two back
in the action or whatever the hell that
was uh and she's just become obliviating
buffoon but she's going after Nikki
Haley and saying that she's not a new
generation she's actually technically
wrong about that uh Nikki Haley is Gen X
Gen X meaning you were born in the mid
60s basically into the late 70s a little
bit into the early 80s I'm 46 years old
I'm right in the middle I was born in 76
I am right in the middle of Gen X Gen X
should be in charge right now the
problem is the Boomers which is a
different generation that's the
generation that Nikki Haley's talking
about and by the way Nikki Haley is not
going after uh Joe Biden because of his
age specifically it's his inability uh
to clearly handle the duties to be
president which are connected to his age
if he was a spry 81 year old if he was a
spry 81 year old I'd be bitching and
moaning about his uh policies all the
time but I wouldn't have a plethora an
endless uh uh an endless amount of
videos that we could go to where he
can't speak properly and everything else
so Whoopi you are technically wrong
because she actually is from another
generation and then Allison Farah there
it's like lady you can throw them a bone
every now and again but they are going
to hate you and they are going to
destroy you and you're a liar you're a
liar too we played the clip the other
day of Allison Farah you know basically
claiming that Ron DeSantis uh you know
that he wants that he's racist because
he wants to get rid of African-American
studies we'll get more to that more on
that in just a second but speaking of
all the people around it so you've got
vivec now clearly he's got some good
ideas you've got Nikki she has a great
track record right successful Republican
governor of a solid strong State South
Carolina U.N Ambassador U.S ambassador
to the U.N under Trump did a good job no
war is peace in the Middle East Etc so
who else might run who might get into
this thing well Ron DeSantis has been
bouncing around he hasn't been in
Florida for the last couple days
fortunately we got a good machine here
so the gov is allowed to travel and
things don't completely fall apart he
went to New York City he went to
Philadelphia and I believe he's on his
way to Chicago or maybe he's getting to
Chicago this morning so the official Ron
DeSantis Twitter account put up this
little compilation of of what he's doing
and why he's doing it we do not
surrender to the woke mob policing in
the spotlight today this morning Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis is in New York the
first of a three-city tour in Florida
our crime rate is at a 50-year low and
we've done it by our commitment to
Public Safety and our support for the
men and women of law enforcement and
contrast that to what we see in some of
these other areas which has had the
polar opposite results high crime
escalating rates they are putting woke
ideology ahead of Public Safety they are
pursuing politics at the expense of the
well-being of those who wear the uniform
and I can promise you this that in
Florida we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob our state is where woke
goes to die
all right so you can see the chips kind
of falling into place right now right
like again I don't know if DeSantis is
running but it certainly seems that way
I'm doing an event with him uh this
Friday in Palm Beach if I try to maybe
I'll ask him a question he could a
little something you know what I mean
like but it does seem that he's going in
that direction but even if he's not the
idea of a guy who is running a massively
successful State saying hey we we've got
the blueprint guys
we've got it right here and we can help
you in New York we can help you in
Illinois we can help you in Pennsylvania
we can help you clean up your streets we
can help get the drugs off the streets
we can help you figure out how to do
policing better and not just have
massive drug markets everywhere and just
the General State Of Mayhem that you
have all over please he's doing it and
that's good whether he runs for
president or not mostly this tour has
been about crime here he has given a
speech uh in New York about what's going
on in the crime Department over there
take a look at the CNN Chiron we're
going to show it to you again after but
look at the subtle ways that they try to
program you take a look we support
strong policies to keep our communities
safe and we back the blue and we support
their mission and we back it up with
money and all kinds of stuff to be able
to do it the reason why you have what
you have in some of these other
jurisdictions is because they're putting
woke ideology ahead of your safety as
New Yorkers or as people from Illinois
or wherever you have this type of policy
taking place okay so the easy stuff is
he goes yeah we fund the police we back
the police so the police are able to do
their job and Florida has all-time low
crime basically across the freaking
board like pretty much everywhere even
in Miami Beach where we get thousands
and thousands of tourists often drinking
late night out partying all the time and
we have record low crime here but did
you catch that CNN Chiron we got it for
you look at this if you want to see how
the mainstream media tries to frame The
Narrative and confuse you and how it is
it is absolute propaganda not journalism
the Chiron they used as Ron DeSantis is
going around talking about the effective
policies of Florida related to policing
desantis's use of government power to
impose agenda worries conservatives
I do not know one conservative that is
worried because Ron DeSantis has funded
the police too much it is a complete lie
now can you find any yes you can find
the Allison Farris you can probably find
the David frums and the Liz cheneys you
can find the complete sellouts but
they're one of the biggest things after
we watch The Summer of Love in the last
couple years of chaos on the streets and
everything else was that the Stark
difference between red and blue was
obvious to everyone and then we saw
which way people moved so the the idea
that CNN so that what they want you to
do there yeah you really need to
understand the game they are playing a
psychological game with their viewers I
know you're not watching it and again I
apologize for having to show you these
clips but we have to address the fact
that a certain set of people are
completely brainwashed and what the
machine does to brainwash them so
they're hearing they're watching that so
if you're the average Democrat and I get
it you already hate the santis because
you're confused and you think he's a
white supremacist and he doesn't like
black people and he hates gay AIDS and
all of this stuff right and it's all
nonsense but you already have that in
your brain then
um you're watching this video of him and
he's making sense right you know well we
fund police officers we don't like you
know Mayhem on the streets that's kind
of what we're doing here in Florida but
they put underneath that because they
don't want you to go that's good what he
just said oh he's upsetting
conservatives he's upsetting
conservatives because suddenly the other
conservatives are really for small
government and it's Ron DeSantis who
wants big government Because he believes
in policing which is complete nonsense
because one of the few things that most
conservatives would agree on relative to
the size of government is that you
should have law and order it is complete
nonsense but he's over the Target right
now so everybody is going after him
Trump's going after him all of the
clowns at MSNBC CNN everybody's going
after him he was on Fox yesterday from
New York and my friend Lisa Booth got to
ask him a question about taking fire
from Pretty much everybody you've come
under a lot of incoming fire recently
Nikki Haley taking aim at you Larry
Hogan as well the governor of Illinois
you know from your visit coming up here
to Chicago
you know what are what's your reaction
to some of those attacks
well Lisa you know if you're an if
you're an office holder and you're just
sitting there twiddling your thumbs and
not getting anything done no one ever
says anything you can kind of just fly
under the radar but when you're out
there leading when you're out there
setting the agenda not just for Florida
but really for the nation which we've
done over the last few years uh people
see that and and the people that don't
necessarily like that are going to
respond accordingly but I can just tell
you uh if people are not firing at me
then I must not be doing my job and so I
view it really as positive feedback
he just gets it it's as simple as that
look I I don't pretend that I'm totally
objective here right I moved to this
state and my life and my business and my
family and my friends were all
flourishing in large part because of
this guy what this guy did so I'm not
sitting here pretending that oh I have
no personal feelings towards this
whatsoever I'm doing what what
journalists uh journalists never do and
again I'm not a journalist they pretend
they don't have any feelings as they
report and try to manipulate you I'm
putting the cards on the table I like
the guy and he's doing an honest job and
that should be protected so Watch What
Happens so he shows up in Illinois now
how many people were killed can I get
the numbers on Chicago I'm really I'm
really taxing you today Phoenix how many
people were killed in Chicago this past
weekend because DeSantis went over to
Illinois and as you know Lori Lightfoot
uh who was by the way incredible in
Beetlejuice she was wonderful people say
that Michael Keaton was the best
Beetlejuice but I've always said it was
Lori life which he's absolutely
wonderful with those bugged out eyes
um she is the mayor of Chicago Chicago
has an insane amount of crime it has
basically the highest uh strictest gun
laws in the entire nation 22 people were
shot in Chicago this weekend only four
were killed so that's pretty good anyway
so DeSantis is always down it was down a
little bit this week good for you
Chicago we're going to film Home Alone 4
there because there a little less murder
it's just so ridiculous right actually
there was probably less murder because
they knew DeSantis was coming to town
and he might do something anyway the
Santa shows up in Chicago and uh the uh
Illinois mayor pritzker uh he's not
happy about it and here he is and just
listen to this dribble the truth is that
we we actually have a much better
education system in Illinois than they
have in Florida we're ranked higher than
they are U.S news and World Report ranks
K-12 education in Illinois sixth in the
country and number one among the largest
states in the country
so he's got nothing to brag about when
it comes to education so uh so he moves
on and tries to use this word woke to
describe everything he doesn't even know
what the word means and he has no
definition of it it's just anything he
doesn't like
I think I misspoke for a second I called
him mayor pritzker but obviously he's
the governor Lightfoot is the mayor of
Chicago he lied right there absolutely
lied when I heard that I was like this
cannot be true this does not ring true
to me so we checked U.S news and World
Report related to education we
screenshot it uh who's number three over
there on education despite no state
income tax so you think we wouldn't be
able to fund the teachers yet we somehow
do yeah Florida is number three we are
actually number one in higher education
and number 16 in K through 12. uh
Illinois yeah they're 11 and uh you know
I didn't get a good Illinois education
but I'm pretty sure that 11 is lower
than three they are number 32 in higher
education and they are number six in
K-12 so he completely lied about that
also in an extended version of that he
went on to say that they are a state
that believes in equity which basically
means they believe in communism clown
ridiculous sensical well perfect
adjectives because I've got a clip here
of that Allison Farah girl going off on
DeSantis saying that he's not really
conservative she is conservative are you
hearing any discomfort among actual
Republican voters
so here's the thing Ron DeSantis is
masterful at commanding National media
attention and culture War stunts and
leaning into the anti-wokeness gets him
talked about it raises his name ID and
it Rouse up the base there are people
like me more in the sununu Larry Hogan
Camp long time lifelong conservatives
who see it as Government overreach
Masters conservative whether it's going
after Disney whether it's dictating from
the state what local schools should
teach rather than that being at the
school board level or decided by parents
um I I do think however this is the
Trump Maga party and I think that the
party is more in line with where Rhonda
Santos is than the more traditional
conservative party that I grew up in
um but I think we're going to Hash that
out I think it's possible sununu gets in
the race I would love to see him make
that intellectual case Larry Hogan
someone who can do it very well as well
and I'm curious to see where Nikki Haley
comes down on this line because it
really is big government conservatism
versus traditional small government
she is such an extraordinary sellout
that in the dictionary under sellout
they should put her name now obviously
that wasn't a clip of the view that was
her on CNN but do you see what it is
when you are a Republican or a
conservative who will sell out all of
your values who will make sure that you
only elect people who never get anything
done or that will always lose you'll
always back losers they will put you on
The View and they will put you on CNN so
again Allison Farah I hope the million
and a half is worth it I really do I
hope you have a nice condo and you know
your hair is nice so I guess you're
getting the carotene treatments or
something that was a pretty solid
reference for me I don't even know what
carotene treatments are but they're
definitely there's something right girls
get carotene treatments on their hair
seems Seems like something okay uh so I
hope it's all worth it because you are
selling your soul to do this nonsensical
drivel Conor made a good point during
that clip she said she was in the sununu
wait this is the new new Hogan Camp
worst
the worst Camp ever these people are
just I'm big for sununu Larry Hogan
that's the group that I want to be part
of it's so effing pathetic it's beyond
imagination here's Joy Reed what's been
a problem for Florida is now a problem
for America it isn't just about the
cruise ship companies or Disney or even
your woke gas stove DeSantis is
determined to Stamp Out intellectual
freedom and it's causing other red
states to scrutinize AP black studies
he's also threatening to withdraw State
support for advanced placement courses
altogether the Miami Herald reports that
top Florida officials are exploring
alternatives to the college board
meeting with the founder of an exam
called the classic learning test
supporters of the exam say it focuses on
the quote great classical and Christian
tradition and the quote centrality of
the western tradition pretty much on
Branford DeSantis who clearly wants to
be president and who is on tour to
signal to the nation how he would govern
and that is by replacing a multitude of
ideas with the one idea he holds dear
the centrality of white Christian
thought and who let's be clear is using
woke to mean any notion that brown black
lgbtq people and women are citizens
rather than subjects who whether they
live in red States or blue States would
in his American Dream be forced to shut
up and do think read and say only what
Ron DeSantis tells them to
actually would be my dream if we lived
in a country where that woman had to
shut up and only listen to what Rhonda
said this is saying however I accept
that I live in a pluralistic democracy
and I don't think Ron DeSantis wants to
do that I'm also fairly certain Ron
DeSantis is not coming for the gays you
know we did a year of this nonsense
don't say gay thing right the bill gets
signed notice you haven't heard anything
about it they haven't been hunting the
gays have you guys you guys live in a
slightly different part of town than I
do are they hunting the gays where you
guys are have you seen any gays running
down the street from Iran DeSantis
Brigade it's all complete nonsense also
Ron DeSantis defending Western thought
yeah that's pretty good uh and this
thing about this like attack on
Christian ideas uh we do live in a
nation built on judeo-christian ideals
these are the good ideals that led to
the ideas related to individual Freedom
that allowed us all to flourish Ron
DeSantis is not racist you people
they're bad people
bad bad people
and
it is what it is but let's continue
because clearly something is happening
here you're watching the machine in real
time all focus on him no but notice
nobody in the machine right now is
focused on Trump right so Trump is on
Truth social and he's sending out his
messages doing his thing and we shall
see what comes of it and as I have said
there is a pretty good chance I'll end
up voting for Trump depending on how
this all shakes out okay I see some
people in the comments upset with me
that I'm not being nice enough to Trump
and it's like first off I'm not part of
a cult I will criticize people as as it
comes across my desk when DeSantis drops
the ball on something horrible I'll
gladly talk about it it's not a problem
I don't I don't worship politicians but
uh the machine right now is all from
every single Direction focused on
DeSantis it's not focused on Trump and
as I have said you were going if the
scientist gets in you are going to see
the machine back Trump MSNBC CNN they
will end up backing Trump they won't be
telling you to vote for Trump but they
will be talking about Trump as much as
possible in a slight slightly more
positive light because they viewed
DeSantis as a threat and Trump will also
get them clicks and Views and that's
what they're in the business of you must
understand that they are not in the
business of telling you news honestly
they are in the business of making sure
that you are stupid and continually
watching their drivel
on that note uh DeSantis did comment on
what's going on now with Biden visiting
Ukraine because clearly he's trying to
get in front of sort of all of the
issues that will be important in 2024. I
thought this was pretty solid things
first on the president's unannounced
visit is this a good move
well you know Brian I'm reminded of uh
when he was Vice President Obama and
Biden uh opposed providing lethal Aid to
Ukraine during those years and then I'm
also reminded that I don't think any of
this would have happened but for the
weakness that the president showed
during his first year in office
culminating of course in the disastrous
withdrawal in Afghanistan so I think
while he's over there I think I and many
Americans are thinking to ourselves okay
he's very concerned about those borders
Halfway Around the World he's not done
anything to secure our own border here
at home we've had millions and millions
of people pour in tens of thousands of
Americans dead because of Fentanyl and
then of course we just suffered a
national humiliation of having China fly
a spy balloon clear across the
continental United States so we have a
lot of problems accumulating here in our
own country that he is neglecting
yeah like it's just true it's just true
Biden's doing nothing about any of that
right and we'll talk about these
Palestinian thing in a second doing
nothing about any of that and he's going
to Ukraine to give them more money and
here's a couple more planes and would
you like some more tanks as if that's
going to end the war but they don't want
the war to end and yes we are at War I
don't care what they tell you is
technically true when we when you are
endlessly funding a war when you are
bankrolling a war and maybe it's other
people's citizens getting killed but if
you are bankrolling it you're in that
war so make it clear we are in this war
and they want more war the machine wants
War there's something sort of beautiful
happening here too because the more that
the Biden Administration goes in on this
and the corporate press obviously wants
it too the more that they go in on this
it gives their Republicans
a really easy clean way of being like
Hey we're the anti-war party now they'll
make that they'll frame that the media
will try to frame that meaning that
you're in bed with Putin of course and
you're a Russian stooge and all that
stuff but at the end of the day putting
aside political parties and everything
else are we running a perfect operation
here in the United States doing
everything right by our citizens with
the clean border and making sure spy
balloons aren't coming over and taking
care of our citizens who are dealing
with these horrific disasters like in
East Palestine so that it would be
sensible for us to be like oh boy we've
really cleaned up our room over here
let's let's see what's going on over
there but we always have more money for
that right we always have more money for
the War Machine and just watch now how
Corporate press
continues to push war here is hack
extraordinaire Joe Scarborough on MSNBC
you look at like for instance Rhonda
sadis who actually went on Fox News
yesterday
and said that Putin doesn't really pose
a risk to his neighbors and uh it just
it's absolutely painful I water it yeah
yeah I know it's just it's absolutely
painful especially
a guy who wants to take control of a
party that Ronald Reagan once LED and
went to the Brandenburg gate and said Mr
Gorbachev tear down this wall what what
a what a uh
what a way to devolve for a party
dentists and other Republicans don't
want this next election or really
anything to be about foreign policy it's
their Achilles heel they don't know
anything about it they don't care the
base they have to deal with
um is actively hostile to any discussion
of foreign policy partly
um you know is it is that anti-salinsky
anti-bidden reflex but partly because
the Republicans have abandoned the the
internationalists the kind of muscular
internationalism that Reagan brought to
the end of the Cold War
um and adopted a kind of sour
no-nothingism about foreign policy and
those are the primary voters and this is
I think why you're seeing the house
being the the house member is somewhat
difficult uh more difficult than the
senate members because that's the very
core of the GOP base that those are the
primary voters that they have to get
past and those voters don't want to hear
anything about foreign policy or NATO or
Ukraine or zielinski because they watch
They Don't Know Much More else
does that clown understand that he's on
TV in a box with five other
know-nothings um and also this this
dismissiveness to the base if the let's
say let's say it actually issued now
first off uh we had four years to Trump
we didn't have wars right we did not
have wars so the idea that they've
abandoned things we had peace through
strength Trump dropped a freaking bomb
in the middle of nowhere remember that
mother of all bombs that he dropped and
then people were like whoa this guy's
kind of nuts let's not test them right
we got I think six peace deals in the
Middle East uh Putin took Georgia under
Bush he took Crimea under Obama he took
nothing under Trump so first off the
idea that Republicans know nothing about
foreign policy is just not true I think
Trump has done an incredible job in
those four years of changing the view of
what foreign policy should be we should
not be nation building we should use our
power judiciously that's number one but
number two the dismissiveness and the
smugness and they can only do this
nowhere could they do this better than
MSNBC The smugness of this guy Tom
Nichols that these people don't care
about foreign policy you know if a truck
if a if a freaking train blew up and
there were 10 000 gallons of ammonia and
all of this toxic and all my water
and in my air and the fish were dying
and my chickens were dead I don't know
that I'd be like could we get some more
money for Ukraine like these people they
are such elitist awful people and guess
what they want World War III
they really do want it and do not forget
I've had David sacks on on the show a
couple times I think he's become one of
the cleanest clearest voices on what is
going on in Ukraine you can fund it you
can give them weapons all of those
things but at the end Putin needs an
off-ramp and we just a couple days ago
had Biden saying we'll fund this as long
as you want and then zelinski saying the
only off-ramp for me is I want to be in
NATO you are telling Putin that you are
screwed man and Putin still has nukes we
will get into that for just a second uh
so here is uh because there it's theater
also you have to understand a lot of
this is just theater There Is No
Business Like Show Business okay so here
is CNN's Alex marquad he was on uh he
was in Kiev when when Biden showed up a
day or two ago and if you want to know
what theater it is sometimes they even
have to show you on CNN
um I've been here for the past five days
I have not heard any explosions I have
not heard any air Sirens until about
half an hour ago right when uh President
Biden was in the center of Kiev as
Clarissa was was just mentioning isn't
that wild isn't that wild no bombs no uh
Sirens no nothing then the president
shows up and oh my God just as he's
walking out into the city center to meet
the guy he's given all the cash too
there's there's bomb alerts and there's
sirens and everything and it's theater
you know it is 100 theater because
nobody ran towards Biden a bombs coming
cover them up you know you at least put
your hand up or an umbrella or something
nobody did that they did it so that you
would hear sirens in the background
again so you would subtly what you would
be seeing and hearing would be
disconnected from reality and you
wouldn't know what to make of it why do
you think we would send our president
whether it was Ronald Reagan or Joe
Biden or Bill Clinton or George should
be wish do you think we send him to a
war zone where there is any threat
whatsoever of him being bombed though
there isn't and even on freaking CNN
they had to admit it Biden gave a big
speech in Ukraine again he has not been
to East Palestine Ohio yet which is
dealing with a unbelievable disaster and
he's very excited about American support
for Ukraine all across my country
the big cities and small towns
Ukrainian Flags flies of American homes
do they I don't know do they I mean I
don't really see any in Florida you know
what I see in Florida I see a lot of um
American flags I see Floridian Flags now
sometimes I see a flag just with an
alligator people are very Pro lizard
here Pro you know reptile okay uh it's
just nonsense but he has to shouldn't
they be the ones flying our flags like
with all that cash you think they'd buy
back a couple flags from us although all
of our flags are made in China so maybe
that doesn't make much sense uh and of
course here he is just ramping it up
it's not this isn't just about Ukraine
it's not just about Russia it's not just
but the US it's the whole world
was Russia invaded it wasn't just
Ukraine being tested
the whole world faced the test for the
ages
Europe was being tested America was
being tested NATO was being tested all
democracies are being tested
and the questions we Face were as simple
as they were profound buddy everybody's
being tested but does anyone throw in
some cash on this thing uh Spain I think
they're a democracy how much are they
throwing in on this thing right does
Brazil count as a democracy anymore I'm
not sure I guess probably not anymore
but they used to be or they're half a
democracy or they were until two weeks
ago are they throw in a little cash or
is anyone throwing in cash now I get it
yes there's a little bit of money
trickling in from other countries but
it's a test for the world and for
democracy we'll fund it to the tilt
sure my son worked at a Ukrainian Energy
company with no expertise and it might
have something to do with what we've
been doing for a long time with this
family and a giant monetary laundering
operation but look over there
uh if you don't think this thing is
ratcheting up uh check this video out so
this is Vladimir Putin at a uh Russian
event this is with a whole bunch of
government officials and they are
announcing he's announcing the
suspension of the Strategic offensive
weapons treaty let me repeat what that
is the Strategic offensive weapons
weapons to attack people they are
suspending their involvement in the
Strategic offensive weapons treaty take
a look operation
[Applause]
is
just to be clear that the guy that was
circled there in the green that was we
grabbed this from Twitter that that
Sergey lavrov he is the foreign minister
of Russia he's under personal sanctions
from the EU the United States
the United Kingdom Canada Japan and
Australia all because of their invasion
in 2022 he was circled in that video for
a separate reason that someone was
commenting on on Twitter uh but this is
the last anti-nuke treaty between Russia
and the west and they are pulling out of
it they are saying we are not going to
be part of this anymore
let me be clear as Joe Biden often says
I am not pro-putin I'm not pro-russia
and I don't think you can just March
your troops into someone else's country
and say we're taking this land even if
we think it was ours and blah blah blah
blah
and I don't think he's a friend of the
West and I don't think he's a friend of
minorities in all of those things but do
you see what is happening here we are on
the slow March being cheered on by the
entire Democrat Party and then every
time a republican comes out say DeSantis
or say certainly say Trump or or any of
these people at this point I don't think
Vivek and we'll see about Nikki Haley I
don't well Nikki Haley may be a little
more in the fight them directly that's a
so there is a split there in the
Republican so I think Nikki would be in
a little more of you fight them I know
she would be I've interviewed her about
it and uh and Pompeo former Secretary of
State he said on my show a couple weeks
ago you have to keep arming them so
there is a split but it's healthy to
have a split on a side like that's how
you debate things that's how you figure
things out but the point is every
Republican and not just Republican every
sane voice on television that is
anti-war anti just oh give him three
more tanks that'll that'll really tilt
the thing you always see this thing like
whoa we gave him five more plays oh oh
oh gosh they've got five more planes
this thing's over no no
it's not how it works they will try to
frame you as a stooge and a puppet and
you're somehow anti-American and you're
pro-russia and all that stuff as we just
inch closer and closer to world war
three like that is real
well
we got a lot of good stuff going on over
here I don't want to go to World War III
um but it does seem to be going in that
direction and here's a little bit more
from MSNBC Andrea Mitchell now you
remember Andrea Mitchell from a couple
days ago She interviewed Kamala Harris
and she completely lied about what was
going on right here with uh Governor
DeSantis and getting rid of that AP
African-American studies class and she
completely lied Kamala lied so she's
just a liar and Joe Scarborough do I
need to explain any more about him uh
they're really big on Biden right now
because Biden's being strong because
he's leading us to war
how badly the war is going and now
Vladimir Putin has to put up with an
image of Joe Biden
walking around the streets of cave you
know I can't tell you how emotionally
and symbolic important that was he
always uh that not just us and the media
but even people at his own party they
always underestimate Joe Biden I will
say that one thing that Newt Gingrich
has said over the years that I actually
agree with was after the 2022 election
said hey Republicans we are
underestimating him just like Democrats
underestimated Ronald Reagan and it
always blew up in our face politically
again they underestimated this guy
does that strike you as journalism or a
giant suck job
what is that what oh my God the I cannot
tell
you what attention
and showing up and they even played the
fake air siren and he walked out there
with his robotic legs and it was all
very exciting and he handed cash to the
guy who seemingly might have blackmail
information on him it's so beyond the
pale bananas that we are at this spot
but that is exactly where we are at
right now and and if you don't see a
stark difference that that's the Silver
Lining this guys I'm telling you the
Stark difference all the Republicans
have to do right now is just keep saying
hey we're just not in the mood to
ratchet this war up and I don't think
most people care about this I I just
don't think I don't think remember Mitch
McConnell what was that two three months
ago the number one issue on most
Republicans mind is the war in Ukraine
no I don't think it's in the top 20. now
if you guys ratcheted up to the point
that we're about to have World War III I
guess people are going to be thinking
about it a little bit more
um but there's got to be a way to
de-escalate this thing and also you just
do you think that Biden do you think
that Lincoln any of these people that
are in charge of any of this do you
think that they are they are honestly
the best people to be doing this
if you do I you're watching the wrong
show uh anyway uh here is ABC because
every now and again what I always tell
you the media one of their tricks is
they're like sort of wholly awful but
every now and again they have to show
you something true so that you don't
tune out completely because your alarms
your Sirens are going off in your head
going man this is mostly most
most people can see it at this point so
now and again they have to show you
something true that's sort of like the
CNN reporter before being like you know
that was a little odd I haven't heard
any sirens for a while suddenly Biden
shows up their Sirens that was them
throwing a little a little crumb uh here
is an ABC reporter uh saying that
actually you know people aren't really
into this Ukraine thing despite Andrea
Mitchell and Joe Scarborough being all
about it and this was about Europe being
tested America being tested NATO being
tested and most importantly democracy
being tested he's making the case that
this is about democracy versus autocracy
and uh you know it's interesting that
this all comes of course as we Mark the
one-year anniversary in Ukraine this is
a time when some countries are beginning
getting to call into question president
zielinski's approach their support for
Ukraine may be starting to waver a
little bit and so Biden today making it
a point to Rally international support
for Ukraine all right so that would be a
good sign right it would be a good sign
if we had more of an anti-war movement
it would be a good sign if some of those
progressives hey I've got a challenge
for you AOC and ilhan Omar and Rashida
Talib I think you're all terrible but
you're at least supposed to be anti-war
so why aren't you at war with your own
party as they lead us to World War III
can you get there
I don't think so because they're
actually they're nothing other than
little pieces of their cogs in a machine
that's all they are
um I don't think most people want this
so how do we shift gears well one way we
could shift gears is by clearly stating
what is going on right here in this
country and say maybe we got to take
care of that first so here's a little
video I want to now get us fully circled
back to where we started Vivek Rama
Swami is running for president uh he did
this interview with Tucker he's made the
full announcement uh and I'm going to
show you a clip now of gay Pete talking
about what's going on in Ohio and then
vivec will be commenting on it and I
think you'll see how we can we can
actually change some Minds by just
clearly stating what the truth is
look Rail City something that uh that
has evolved a lot over the years but
there's clearly more that needs to be
done because while this uh horrible
situation has gotten a particularly high
amount of attention there are roughly 1
000 cases a year of a train derailing
particularly high amount of attention
because this happens two three times a
day the vacant I mean it's just it's
unbelievable that he said that out loud
this is appalling I mean look at what
the people in this town and this
community are going through and to be
able to be that callous to just turn
that into a statistic is just appalling
and says a lot about how the leadership
condescends on the people of this
country I'm talking to you from Ohio
today but on the other hand I've gone to
school at Harvard with people like Pete
Pete and I actually overlapped in
college and I will just tell you the
Dirty Little Secret is this okay people
in other parts of the country do not
take something like this as seriously
when it happens in flyover country like
Ohio if this had happened in New York
City or Washington DC this would be a
very different story in terms of
national media attention in terms of
attention from our government leaders
and the fact that he's even implying
that this has gotten too much attention
because it's just another statistic I
think reveals exactly why people in that
town of East Palestine do not trust the
leaders who are in charge because
they've been given no reason to trust
them and if it happened in New York
Buddha judge would have been there on
day one
you see why it's good that he's running
it does not matter whether you think he
can win or not getting someone who can
clearly articulate these ideas get out
there and stand up and and it was
freaking at Harvard while Pete was there
telling you this is how these people
think and we all know damn well if that
freaking disaster happened in New York
City or DC as they referenced Pete would
have been there in a minute he would
have got on his little bike and he would
have gotten there in a minute well he
would have gotten in the truck with the
bike and then a block out before the
cameras got there they would have put
him on the bike and he would have biked
over there with his little bike little
bike helmet and the whole thing
um
we have to do better and I think we can
do better and I think some good people
are getting involved and that that will
be our chance this is exactly how we
will shift gears people are wavering in
their support for Ukraine their endless
support and it doesn't mean they're
Russian Stooges or mean or selfish or
anything else we care more about Ohio I
do period I care more about the people
of Ohio than I do about the people of
Ukraine okay this is our home this is
our country and and I'm just not going
to follow these war mongers on their
path to World War III they're going to
try to take us there uh but you know
what if we can get good people
communicating the right ideas whether
it's bevec whether it's DeSantis whether
it's Trump we have a chance to fight the
thing
and I like our chances ladies and
gentlemen we've got a post game show
coming up for you at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 51
seconds as a reminder my Friday show
will be the first ever show first ever
live stream shot at rumble's new studio
in Sarasota it will only be on Rumble
and locals not on YouTube so go to
rumble.com Ruben report and subscribe
over there we've got a quick cold close
for you and I'll see you in a few
seconds
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]